my Anime Expo with Hassan boy boy and I
did a thing and I'm gonna find out what
their worst food take is I do not eat
any sushi you're a weeb and you don't
eat sushi or shellfish and you've been
to Japan twice now in a matter of five
months when I go combining food all the
way tamagosandos I'm getting all the
wagyu I'm eating all the cows in Japan
but that's it no sushi what's your worst
food today I don't know how meant to
follow that that was the most disgusting
thing I've ever heard I've never been in
a drive-through I think no one should
ever eat food in a car ever
Alex what is your worst food take I
think if you eat a carrot you think
about the taste and then if you eat a
mango and you identify that flavor it's
exactly the same flavor what carrots and
mangoes are the same what but you have
to do it